this wind / productions video was made
possible by hover get your unique domain
and email from hover by going to hover
calm / 1 / and using the code Wendover
at checkout it will be a cold day in
hell before I let twins fly long haul /
water routes those were the words of
Lynn Helms administrator of the Federal
Aviation Administration during the
Reagan administration at the time no
commercial American airplane with two
engines was allowed to fly anywhere
farther than 60 minutes for my diversion
Airport the belief was that if one
engine failed the other could only
safely fly the plane for about an hour
but this rule severely limited what
smaller planes could do on North
Atlantic routes like New York to London
twin-engine planes could only fly in
these areas but a direct route looked
like this the options were to either fly
a twin-engine plane on an inefficient
routing or fly an inefficient three or
four engine plane there was no place for
long and skinny routes between smaller
cities using smaller planes since
airlines couldn't legally fly those
smaller planes if this one simple rule
changed the very way airplanes were
built now in the 60s this 60 minute
regulation only applied to planes with
two engines of course aircraft
manufacturers could build quad engine
jets but those had to be huge for
Airlines to make their money's worth
with the high fuel consumption the 747s
of the time could carry more than 400
passengers they could therefore only fly
on super high demand routes like New
York to London to have any hope of being
full in order to start flying more
convenient non-stop routes from smaller
markets planes had to get smaller while
still being legally allowed to hop the
pond
that's where tri Jets came into play
with three engines these planes were in
subject to the same 60 minute regulation
as twin Jets they could easily fly any
transatlantic route that's why in the
70s and 80s the long-haul Jets you'd see
at airports were for the most part
either 747s or tri jets like the dc-10
this 60 minute regulation was
inconvenient for Atlantic crossings but
in the Pacific it actually changed how
Hawaii as a state developed there are
zero diversion airports between
California and
why so the route isn't even close to
covered under the 60 minute rule as a
result airlines could only fly huge
planes between the mainland and Hawaii
which meant the planes could pretty much
only fly to Honolulu
there was virtually no service to the
other islands from the mainland which
meant they were severely isolated that's
part of the reason why the tourism
industry only picked up on the other
islands in recent decades the 60-minute
rule originated from the days of piston
driven propeller aircraft with these it
was far more common for engines to just
stop working mid-flight that's why there
were contingency engines the regulations
just didn't adapt to the increased
reliability of jet engines statistically
for every failure of a jet engine there
are a hundred and seventeen piston
engine failures once the jet age rolled
in engine failure just wasn't as much of
a concern so in 1985 the FAA but
grudgingly granted permission to Trans
World Airlines to fly their twin-engine
767 direct between Boston and Paris
route taking it up to a hundred and
twenty minutes away from diversion
airports this was the first example of a
brand-new FAA certification called ETOPS
extended-range twin-engine operational
performance standards or more
colloquially engine's turn or passenger
swim before an airline can fly on long
overwater route they have to buy a plane
with what's known as an e tops type
rating basically that means that the
plane was built with adequate
redundancies communication systems and
fire suppression systems to fly safely
if one engine fails for example the 767
the first plane to get an e top
certification has a type rating of a
hundred and eighty minutes meaning it
can fly anywhere as long as it's within
a hundred and eighty minutes from a
diversion airport but just because a
plane has an e tops type rating doesn't
mean an airline can fly it ETOPS
they have to have a special maintenance
plan a special flight crew special cabin
crew special dispatchers special fuel
quantities and special passenger
recovery plans sense just because
there's a runway doesn't mean a plane
can safely divert since the emergency
doesn't necessarily end once the plane
lands Cold Bay Alaska for example is a
perfect diversion Airport
routes between Asia and North America it
only has six commercial flights per week
nowadays but as a former air force base
it has an enormous runway the only issue
is that the town of Cold Bay has a
population of a hundred and eight it's
tiny so any diversions automatically
double or triple the amount of people in
the small town there certainly aren't
enough hotel rooms or restaurants to
house and feed stranded passengers
so if airlines plan to use Cold Bay as a
diversion Airport they need to make a
plan for how to house feed and recover
passengers within 48 hours of landing
last year an American Airlines 77 was
flying from Shanghai to Chicago when
it's right engine had an issue halfway
across the Pacific Ocean the plane
quickly took a left turn diverting to
Cold Bay even before landing the
passenger recovery plan was implemented
as flight attendants served a second
meal service early just a few hours
after safely landing in Cold Bay
Americans mechanics took off from
Seattle bound for Cold Bay to start
fixing the plane while Alaska Airlines
Americans partner sent a 737 from
Anchorage to pick up the stranded
passengers meanwhile flight attendants
served the third set of meals they had
stocked while waiting on the ground and
the Coast Guard opened their heated
hangar to passengers just 10 hours after
the emergency landing passengers were on
their way to Anchorage where they spent
the night before taking an American 757
to Chicago that was a perfect example of
how the passenger recovery plan worked
the quick response and defined plan
helped to the airline get passengers out
safely and quickly now because of this
solid engine reliability numerous
redundancies and well-designed passenger
recovery plans airlines and airplanes
can now receive some insane ETOPS
certifications the 787 dreamliner the
plane that diverted to Cold Bay has a
type rating of 330 minutes that means it
can fly up to five and a half hours away
from a diversion Airport certain routes
over long ocean stretches in the
southern hemisphere were theoretically
possible in the past with four engine
planes but were economically impossible
since airlines could never fill the
large planes on the low demand city
pairs like Melbourne to Santiago with
the ETOPS 330 certification let
palm airlines can fly their small 787
economically on this relatively low
demand route across the South Pacific
the Airbus a350 is even rated for ETOPS
370 it can fly six hours and ten minutes
away from diversion airports this plane
can therefore fly everywhere on earth
except directly over the South Pole
because of this simple rule change three
and four engine planes are largely a
relic of the past boeing and airbus --is
largest jets are both there only four
engine planes in production the 747 and
a380 nearly all North Atlantic traffic
today is on twin-engine planes as
smaller and smaller planes getty tops
certifications Air Canada for example
flies their tiny 120 passenger a 319
with atop certification daily between
st. John's Airport and London Heathrow
British Airways even sends the even
smaller III 18 between New York and
London City Airport these routes
would've been unimaginable 30 years ago
but the reliability of the airplanes of
today mean that we need not fear flying
small planes over big oceans this video
was made possible by hover I talked last
time about how hover is a fantastic way
to get a unique domain just like my new
Wendover dot productions domain but I
want to stress this time just how
professional a custom email address is
for $5.00 for the entire year I set up
an email ending in a twin divert dot
productions to forward to my existing
business email not only is this email
much more memorable it also uses
professionalism surely that's worth the
five dollars that you'd otherwise spend
on one one hundred and sixtieth of an
etops flight to London right anyways you
can get a custom domain and email from
hover for ten percent off while
simultaneously supporting Wendover
productions by going to hover com slash
went over and using the code Wendover at
checkout once again that's hover comm
slash Wendover and the code Wendover for
10% off your custom professional unique
domain and email with hover
you